chuckles back now with part two of
series is college worth it the key to
success in this country and a degree
from a brand name school as a virtual
guarantee of future wealth and power and
we believe it is then one of the most
important questions we can ask about
America is this how exactly did you get
into a prestigious university what are
the standards
well remarkably nobody really knows the
answer
college admissions is a bewildering
mystery to most of us it's a treasure
map with the directions obscured and
that's not an accident colleges
consistently refused to explain how they
admit students usually it takes legal
action to find out secrecy is the key to
their power and they guard it jealously
but there are some facts available
thanks to whistleblowers in college
admissions offices in a series of civil
rights lawsuits filed over the years we
do know something about admission
standards the main thing to understand
going in is that no matter what you may
have heard higher education is not
really a meritocracy there aren't a lot
of slow kids at Harvard but that doesn't
mean the smartest and hardest-working
applicants get in often they don't get
in other factors come into play
the first and probably the least
publicized of these is legacy admissions
you're more likely to get into a
prestigious school if your parents went
there much more likely it turns out a
2011 study of 30 elite universities
found that the children of undergraduate
alumni were on average 45 percent more
likely to get in an earlier study found
the legacy advantage was equivalent to
an additional hundred and sixty points
on the SAT that's a major leg up
colleges understand that admitting the
kids of alumni help with fundraising
they don't like to talk about that but
it's true the other factor that colleges
don't like to talk about is affirmative
action the Supreme Court banned the use
of racial quotas in admissions some
years ago but in real life that decision
meant nothing skin color remains a
central consideration at every level of
the process
the average admissions offices every bit
as race-conscious as any institution in
the Jim Crow South and
are less transparent about it the
numbers tell the story every study there
have been a few of them has shown a huge
discrepancy between the achievement that
colleges require of applicants of
different racial groups this is true at
the undergraduate level and at the
graduate level the new analysis of
recent data from the Association of
American Medical Colleges for example
found that African American students
with low scores in the med school
admissions test an average grades had a
fifty-six percent chance of getting into
med school at the other end
Asian students with the exact same
scores and grades had a six percent
chance of getting in so facts like these
have spurred lawsuits from groups
individuals alleging discrimination and
in every case the data they've unearthed
proof there's been discrimination
defenders of the current system though
say that nobody is being discriminated
against and that race has nothing to do
with these numbers of course no one
actually believes that consider this
example at Cal Tech which has a rare
race-neutral admissions policy the
student body was 43% Asian in 2013 at
Harvard which erect quotas against
Asians as it once did against Jews that
number was 18% roughly where it has been
for years even as the number of Asian
applicants has risen when skin color
becomes a criterion for admission some
people lose but who exactly wins no one
ever asked that now we know who's
supposed to benefit affirmative action
was designed to level the playing field
for Americans whose ancestors had been
discriminated against primarily this
meant black applicants yet fifty years
after affirmative action began the
percentage of African Americans that
many elite colleges appears to be
dropping even as schools boast about
being diverse how is that happening
simple foreigners are taking their place
under the rules of race-conscious
admissions the son of a Nigerian tycoon
meets the same standards and checks the
same box as the son of a single mother
from the southside of Chicago
both are black so for the purposes of
diversity goals they're exactly the same
but in fact they're not the same at all
one is poor American and descended from
people brought to this country by force
you probably want to help that kid the
other is a rich foreigner well-connected
and far more likely to have attended as
elective private school he doesn't need
your help yet who has a better chance of
leveraging diversity standards to get
into Harvard you know the answer the
rich kid does he gets an advantage he
hasn't earned and doesn't deserve and
that's a win for him
Harvard wins too it gets to brag about
being inclusive meanwhile the kid on the
south side of Chicago doesn't go to
college at all this is happening at
schools all over this country and the
trend is accelerating as immigration
accelerates the 2007 study found that
among black students at the top 28
American universities the percentage of
immigrants was about double the
representation in the broader population
at Ivy League school students from
immigrant families accounted for fully
41 percent of black freshmen at Harvard
a study three years earlier found that
two-thirds of all black undergraduates
were from immigrant backgrounds this is
the opposite of what affirmative action
was designed to do yet over time the
definition of who was eligible for a
front of action has expanded even
further moving even farther away from
where it began in many places illegal
aliens now qualify for lower admission
standards universally identifying as
Hispanic rather than white gives
applicants the equivalent of a hundred
and thirty points on the SAT so this is
a huge advantage for newly arrived
immigrants over native-born Americans
yet it's puzzling if you think about it
why should the descendant of Spanish
conquistadors get preference over the
great grandchild of indentured Irish
servants what injustice is resolved by
putting one over the other how is that
fair how is it just well of course it
isn't fair or just which is why it has
never explained or defended only imposed
Americans lose in this arrangement
African Americans get shafted completely
in favor of foreigners with no
connection to this country or its
history yet few complain about this
because almost nobody really understands
what is happening and that's why the
admissions process is secret so you
won't challenge it Kathryn layman is
chairman of the u.s. Commission on civil
rights she spoke with us about all of
this just a minute ago
thank you very much for coming on thank
you for having so what's the purpose of
affirmative action what do we have it
well the goal is to make sure that our
colleges and universities have a chance
to achieve the diversity that they say
that they want for their schools where
the long-standing precedent is that they
can use affirmative action if there are
no other means to achieve that diversity
and to be able to satisfy their
education on this so it's not a an
attempt to redress past wrongs it's
simply for the sake of variety well it
started as an attempt to address past
wrongs I think that goal continues to
exist but the reality is that schools
have of long-standing said that what
they want to do is to educate students
to live in work in be prepared for an
increasingly global society and to be
able to be full participants in the
world that they will enter and so
achieving diversity is one way of making
sure that students are able to be
educated toward that end so if you
factor sports out of it and this has
been done and you reduce it to grades
and test scores it still remains true
that Asians East Asians Chinese
particularly in Koreans score what five
hundred points higher than other groups
with the same admissions rates and so
here's a here's a flaw in your analysis
yes you're reducing it to the test
scores and the grades which the court
has said specifically you cannot do the
the school's the colleges the
universities have a First Amendment
academic freedom interest in selecting
whom they want to educate and how they
want to educate them and what they say
discrimination and if we're happening to
any other group of course there'd be a
total outrage well I think I think it
would be a total outrage for
discrimination period what the court has
said is that that's not how to analyze
it and that that's not discrimination
the court has said you take a look at
whether the school is analyzing all of
who a child is no I'm aware what the
court says I just don't think it passes
the common sense test but do you think
if you can see that part of the purpose
of affirmative action and I think the
purpose that most Americans the debt
would identify with if there's any part
of it that they would is the idea that
you know there are groups in American
particularly African Americans who are
discriminated against sis directly and
this is a way of making good on that
birth trying so how does it make you
feel when you see the numbers
that foreign-born black students
displace african-american students
especially prestigious schools at a
really high rate and then the school
gets to say we're diverse when they're
letting in you know the kid of the
Nigerian ambassador doesn't that seem a
perversion of the purpose well I think
it might be a perversion of the purpose
I haven't seen those numbers and that's
not my experience from investigating the
schools and in fact what we're seeing
now in particular in this administration
with its hostility to having people come
to this country from other countries
we're seeing a drop-off in international
students at our schools in a way that is
affecting the bottom line but let's say
something let's say I'll get the exact
numbers in a sec but let's say you know
I don't know 19% of all black people in
the United States were foreign-born but
the percentage of black students at
prestigious schools were foreign-born
was like 45% that would suggest that
they're disproportionately getting the
slots that most of us think are going to
African Americans you don't think that's
a problem
well I again we need to resist your
reduction of the applicant to a
particular characteristic rather than
look at the whole police force of course
reduce them to that I mean they're
really very conscious in the way that
they do admission you know let me tell
you that that is just not true that the
schools are pretty opaque in the way
that they do their admissions and that's
that's a problem for the American public
but I've overseen investigations in
college and universities unexecuted is
topic and what I've seen time and time
and time again is that the schools
actually do a very good job of taking a
look at what the students say about
themselves what their recommenders time
is why can't we judge it for ourselves
since this is the gateway to wealth and
power in this country a degree from this
prestigious school and the government
subsidies are overwhelming and the tax
breaks are overwhelming why don't I have
a right to know what the criteria are
that they're using you know Tucker I'm a
huge believer in transparency I think it
would be better for the American public
to have more information when I was at
the office for civil rights we entered
into a resolution agreement with
Princeton on this topic and we evaluated
exactly this question and we made our
analysis very public to be able to share
what people's questions were and what
our analysis was one totally with you on
that I think knowing more is better
Kevin thanks for joining us thanks very
much for having me